das tagesgespräch bei phoenix heute mit
sahne röser die bundesvorsitzende des
verbandes die jungen unternehmer größe
ganz herzlich sie wollen heute
demonstrieren gehen vor peter altmaier
treffen mit den 40 wirtschaftsverbänden
warum
ja ich kann ihnen sagen es ist fünf nach
zwölf für den deutschen mittelstand und
viele unternehmen viele betriebe stehen
wirklich mit dem rücken zur wand wir
haben kaum planungssicherheit und keine
perspektive und wie das gerade schon den
beitrag gesehen haben es wurde wirklich
viel bumms und eine bazooka für die
unternehmen versprochen und angekündigt
und was geblieben ist ist tatsächlich
legt eine wasserpistole und bei vielen
unternehmens sind die wirtschaftshilfen
bis heute noch nicht angekommen und sie
sind miserabel organisiert und deswegen
haben wir von seiten der jungen
unternehmer gesagt wir fordern eine
öffnung strategie wir fordern eine
schnellere umsetzung der hilfen und
deswegen gehen wir heute auch auf die
straße
also wumms und bazooka stammen ja von
minister scholz demonstrieren sie bei
dem auch also wir kritisieren
tatsächlich das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium als auch
das finanzministerium
hier wird wirklich vom ministerium zur
ministerium der schwarze peter
zugespielt was wir aber jetzt brauchen
ist eine schnelle unterstützung und
hilfe das brauchen die geschlossenen
unternehmen und da muss schluss sein mit
dieser miserablen organisation mit der
miserablen und schlechten zusammenarbeit
zwischen den ministerien was es braucht
ist wirklich eine verlässliche
orientierung wir brauchen objektive
kriterien wann die einschränkungen
stufenweise wieder aufgehoben werden und
wann wer wieder öffnen darf da brauchen
wir jetzt als wirtschaft eine
perspektive und da steht herr
bundesminister altmaier als auch herr
bundesminister scholz in der hand
fordern sie auch wir die zum beispiel
die werte union den rücktritt eines der
beiden ministers zb von peter hartmann
das kann jetzt nicht die lösung sein was
wir brauchen die gerade eben schon
erwähnt ist eine schnelle umsetzung eine
gute organisation vor allem klare
ansagen
wir brauchen einen stufenplan und wir
haben ja gesehen einige bundesländer als
auch die fdp haben schon gute konzepte
vorgelegt wie so ein stufenplan aussehen
kann und es wird doch jetzt nicht so
schwer sein diese guten konzepte in
einen bus zu bringen in einen eröffnungs
plan damit die geschlossenen betriebe
endlich wieder erwirtschaften können
weil wie bereits erwähnt viele
unternehmen geht die luft aus die hilfen
sind bis dato nicht angekommen sie
können sich nicht mehr über wasser
halten haben viel von ihrem eigenkapital
jetzt aufgebraucht und deswegen braucht
es eine schnelle öffnung natürlich unter
berücksichtigung der infektionszahlen
vor ort das heißt man muss in die
regionen man muss in der regel
landkreise schauen weil es bringt uns
nichts wenn es in hamburg regnet dass
wir in stuttgart gummistiefel anziehen
das bedeutet wir brauchen auch den blick
auf die region und was sinnvoll ist und
was vor allem auch möglich ist also das
heißt sie betonen dass regionale sollte
einen blick genommen werden wie ist es
mit ihrer forderung in richtung testen
selbst testen und schnell testen
absolut er das testen ist ein ganz
wichtiger und elementarer baustein damit
wir einen überblick bekommen ich mache
wenn wir nach österreich schauen
österreich testet ja momentan
millionenfach wenn man dort ein bild
friseurbesuch vorhat dann testet man
sich das heißt schnelltest aber auch
tester stationen die beispielsweise 24
stunden geöffnet sind könnten hier her
wir müssen uns aber auch daran
orientieren nicht nur an den sident
zahlen in den regionen sondern wir
müssen uns auch orientieren an der
auslastung der intensivstation
die zahl der impfungen thema impfungen
das geht ja auch sehr schleppend voran
vor allem bei den risikogruppen müssen
die hier wirklich tempo gewinnen wir
müssen die verfügbaren text tests
berücksichtigen und wir müssen wir
gerade schon angesprochen wirklich von
landkreis zu landkreis dann auch
entscheiden
und wie gesagt wir haben haben keine
zeit mehr für eine hinhaltetaktik und
wir erwarten uns auch heute von dem
wirtschaftsgipfel kein wischiwaschi
sondern klare aussagen und auch eine
klare strategie so sicher dass diese
klaren aussagen klaren strategien kommen
wollte ja das ist unsere erwartung an
der bundesminister altmaier aus dem
gespräch wir hoffen dass wir jetzt
endlich diesen eröffnungs klaren
vorgelegt bekommen dass wir eine
perspektive bekommen damit wir wissen
welche schritte jetzt zu tun sind damit
wir wissen wer wann wie öffnen darf wer
aber vielleicht dann auch wieder
schließen muss wenn die infektionszahlen
nach oben gehen
wir adressieren diese erwartungen an
herrn altmaier aber auch an das
finanzministerium was die finanziellen
hilfen betrifft und erwarten hier auch
wirklich jetzt schnelle lösungen weil
was wir bis dato erlebt haben sind große
versprechungen große ankündigungen was
wir aber faktisch sehen sein ziel ist
dass die november und dezember helfen
und wir haben jetzt mitte februar immer
noch nicht bei den betroffenen
unternehmen angekommen sind und auf
diese versprechungen auf diese
ankündigungen müssen wir uns als
unternehmen als wirtschaft auch
tatsächlich verlassen können aber ich
kann ihnen sagen das vertrauen in die
politik von seiten der wirtschaft von
seiten der unternehmer schwindet von tag
zu tag man kann schon fast nicht mehr
glauben was dort ausgesprochen wird von
daher erwarten wir von seiten der jungen
unternehmer und wir als deutscher
mittelstand wirklich verlässliche
aussagen klare aussagen
einen plan wie wir jetzt die letzte
nächsten wochen und monate auch mit
diesem virus leben können wie wir mit
diesen lg virus auch wirtschaften können
ich glaube wir haben von seiten der
familienunternehmer schon im letzten
london bewiesen dass wir schneller
umsetzen können wir haben jede konzepte
neben umgesetzt und ja wir sind leider
mit unserer zeit durch ich hätte auch
gern noch über die grenzkontrollen mit
ihnen gesprochen aber das schaffen wir
nicht mehr wir machen uns jetzt
allerdings im beitrag ich sag ihnen
herzlich danke schön für das gespräch